schönen guten tag auch von meiner seite
robert bei dem was du gerade gesagt hast
habe ich sehr an unserem parteitag vor
drei jahren gedacht und ich glaube viele
andere grüne
auch damals war unser motto und das ist
erst der anfang wir wussten vor drei
jahren natürlich nicht dass wir heute
hier stehen
aber was wir wussten robert und ich und
viele andere ist dass wir unsere partei
öffnen wollen dass wir politik für die
breite der gesellschaft machen wollen
einladend und mit klaren zielen und so
beginnt heute ein neues kapitel für
unsere partei
und wenn wir es gut machen auch für
unser land
wir haben eine klare idee einer
kanzlerschaft für deutschland ich möchte
heute hier mit meiner kandidatur ein
angebot machen für die gesamte
gesellschaft als einladung unser
vielfältiges starkes reiches land in
eine gute zukunft zu führen
dafür sind so ehrlich müssen wir seien
veränderungen nötig und wir können diese
veränderungen
wir müssen sie aber auch machen wir
müssen sie machen für ein gerechtes land
in dem kitas und schulen wirklich die
schönsten orte sind ein land in dem
pflegekräfte wirklich zeit und vor allem
ressourcen haben sich um die menschen zu
kümmern
ein land in dem der staat digital
funktioniert und seinen bürgerinnen und
bürgern dient ein diverses und
weltoffenes land werte basiert und eine
wehrhafte demokratie in deutschland im
herzen europas
ein land in dem klimaschutz das
zukünftige fundament schafft für
wohlstand freiheit und sicherheit ein
klimaschutz der auch die pendlerin auf
dem land mit denkt ein klimaschutz für
alleinerziehende mit geringem einkommen
für industriearbeiter damit wir
alle gut leben können ich war in diesem
historischen abend der pariser
klimakonferenz in paris mit dabei als
laurent fabius damalige französische
außenminister und chefverhandler der
pariser klimakonferenz an diesem abend
seine holzhammer namen und sagte das
abkommen ist angenommen
da standen menschen die sich
logischerweise nicht kannten delegierte
aus 194 ländern
mit tränen in den augen im raum und
fielen sich in die arme
vor fünf jahren wir müssen uns die zeit
noch mal vorstellen moment wo so viele
gezweifelt und gehadert haben können wir
wirklich die großen großen
herausforderungen unserer zeit lösen
endlich wieder ein großes
internationales abkommen zu schaffen und
ich stand in diesem ganzen getöse und
neben ja meine kleine tochter sechs
monate alt in ihrem kinderwagen und ich
dachte so wenn sie so alt ist wie ich
heute 35 im jahr 2050 das ja für das
diese klimakonferenz seine großen ziele
formuliert hat dann wird sie vielleicht
auch kleine kinder haben da bin ich
großmutter
dann werden wir klimagerechten wohlstand
geschaffen haben müssen
klimaschutz ist die aufgabe unserer zeit
die aufgabe meiner generation und
entsprechend will ich dass die politik
einer neuen bundesregierung klimaschutz
für alle bereiche zum maßstab macht um
paris zu erfüllen
für all das braucht es jetzt mut dinge
wirklich anders zu machen
zukunft ist nichts was einfach so
passiert wir haben es in der hand und
deshalb stehe ich heute hier was alles
nicht geht das haben wir jetzt in den
letzten jahren genug gehört
aber es zählt jetzt was alles geht was
alles möglich ist
und genau diesen anspruch das hat robert
habe gerade ja noch mal deutlich gemacht
dieses angebot haben wir gemeinsam in
den letzten jahren in unsere partei
getragen aber eben auch ins land
getragen verändern statt zu versprechen
jetzt ist die zeit in diesem sinne eine
gute regierung anzuführen und politik
jedenfalls so wie ich politik erlebe
wirkt immer im konkreten in konkreten
für die menschen für die menschen in
ihrer vielfalt in ihrer
unterschiedlichkeit und deswegen müssen
wir politik auch aus dem konkreten
heraus machen an so vielen orten in
unserem land gibt es so viele beispiele
und das neue schon realität ist die
gesundheitsregion gerade auch in
ländlichen regionen wo pflegekräfte wo
ärztinnen und ärzte therapeuten zusammen
arbeiten um in der fläche alle gut zu
versorgen
die kommune die tatsächlich schon zu 100
prozent erneuerbaren energien sich
versorgt die schule die komplett
digitalisiert ist und dann noch eine
schulküche und der musikverein mit an
ort an bord hat es geht es geht aber all
das funktioniert nur weil ausnahmen von
festgefahrenen alten regeln geschaffen
wurden
in diesem ausnahme modus allein kommen
wir aber nicht weiter
es gilt jetzt neue regeln zu schaffen
und zwar so dass das fortschrittliche
dass das beste nicht die ausnahme ist
sondern der zukünftige standard in
unserem land in unserem europa steckt so
wahnsinnig viel so viele menschen
bringen sich ein mit ihrer innovation
mit ihrer leidenschaft mit ihr mut und
mit ihrer tatkraft
ich will dass wir all das entfesseln
dass wir das beste was in diesem land
steckt auch wirklich möglich machen
für die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
europäischen industrie für unseren
mittelstand vor unserer handwerker und
für eine lebendige kultur
dafür müssen wir investieren in
forschung und den sozialen zusammenhalt
in polizeiwachen und gerichtssäle in die
digitale verwaltung und
schnelles internet und all das verlangt
veränderungen und diese veränderung ist
aber nur möglich wenn wir auch eine
andere politische kultur pflegen in der
man sich wertschätzt kritische stimmen
ernst nimmt und nicht gegeneinander
arbeitet sondern miteinander eine grüne
kanzlerin kandidatur steht für ein neues
verständnis von politischer führung
entschieden und transparent lernfähig
und selbstkritisch demokratie lebt vom
wechsel ja ich war noch nie kanzlerin
auch noch die ministerin
ich trete an für erneuerung für den
status quo stehen andere
ich bin zutiefst davon überzeugt dass
dieses land einen neuanfang braucht um
gut durch dieses neue herausfordernde
jahrzehnt zu kommen
mit diesem auf sicht fahren das haben
aber schon immer so gemacht und wenn es
dann doch sein muss dann drehen wir halt
noch ein stellschräubchen weiter
da kommen wir nicht weiter ich möchte
anbieten eine politik die vorausschau
auf die was neues wagt die die menschen
zuhört und ihn aber auch wirklich was
zutraut eine politik die bei aller
notwendigkeit auch harte entscheidungen
zu treffen
menschlich und empathisch bleibt ich
komme aus einer generation die nicht
mehr jung ist aber auch nicht alt einer
generation die in einem geeinten
deutschland und in einem gemeinsamen
europa erwachsen geworden ist das
fundament auf dem wir stehen haben
generationen vor uns hart erarbeitet wir
haben jetzt die aufgabe das gute das
beste in die zukunft zu tragen
die verbundenheit der generation ist für
mich grundlage für eine starke
gesellschaft jugendliche die im panini
zeiten auf ihre freiheit auf ihren er
eigentlich auf alles was es ausmacht
jung zu sein verzichtet haben
um ältere menschen zu schützen
großeltern die in sorge ostern nicht
erleben zu können jetzt endlich frische
luft ihre enkelkinder wieder sehen
können und manche von ihnen morgens ihr
enkelkind für die schule testen
rentnerin demonstrieren mit teenagern
für klimaschutz weil es sie eben nicht
kalt lässt wie die nachbarskinder in 30
jahren leben
das ist gelebte solidarität und in
diesem sinne mache ich politik
ich weiß wie groß die verantwortung ist
wie hoch die erwartung an uns und auch
an mich das was da kommt hat robert
habeck bereits gesagt das wird uns als
partei gehörig fordern
es wird nicht immer leicht sein aber wir
gehen das gemeinsam an nicht nur robert
habeck und ich nicht nur wir als bündnis
grünen bündnis 90 die grünen insgesamt
sondern vor allen dingen als eine
gesellschaft die so viel weiter ist als
die politik die größte kraft wie
entwickelt man immer nur zusammen
viele sind in diesem jahr der pandemie
erschöpft
der spinnt spannung in der gesellschaft
es gibt natürlich widerstreitende
unterschiedliche interessen
aber es gibt halt so viele die bereit
sind verantwortung zu übernehmen
auch über ihr eigenes wohl hinaus die
eigentlich gestalten wollen
in deutschland steckt so viel
wir haben das auto erfunden und das
fahrrad die energiewelt revolutioniert
wir haben gemeinsam unter größten druck
bin kürzester zeit ein impfstoff
entwickelt
jeden tag setzten sich menschen setzen
sich lehrerin und pfleger forscherin und
landwirte ehrenamtlich für diese
gesellschaft ein
jeden tag wachsen sie über sich hinaus
jetzt ist es an der zeit dass politik
über sich hinauswächst dass ihr zukunft
gestalten
das ist mein angebot das ist unser an
gebot dafür treten wir an